figureau live bonjour on est en direct
aujourd'hui pour notre nouvelle émission
science du figaro science j + 1 une
émission pour laquelle nous allons
analyser décortiquer une nouvelle
scientifiques récentes et ce jeudi nous
allons parler trou noir avec tristan v
bonjour tristan bonjour bien sûr tout au
long de l'année vous n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions comme d'habitude
tristan juste une petite question rapide
pour commencer c'est la photo de l'année
on peut le dire aubin chacun voit midi à
sa porte mais pour les
les astronomes en tout cas oui c'est
clairement la photo de l'année en
sciences je pense aussi et c'est
clairement un cliché historique qui
restera qui entrera dans les livres
d'école et donc à ce titre oui je
pensais pas tous les jours qu'une photo
rentrer dans les manuels scolaires et il
sera probablement encore pour quelques
années allez on en parle tout de suite
tristan on a derrière nous cette photo
on voit l'affiché en un peu plus grand
pour que nos auditeurs le nos
internautes le voit bien cette photo on
peut le dire elle est floue quand même
c'est tout ça pour ça on va dire oui
alors il ya eu un grand débat sur
internet est ce qu'elle est flou est ce
qu'elle est pas floues à tout dépend de
ce qu'on entend par par flou mais dans
le sens le plus commun oui elle est
floue c'est à dire qu'on voit pas la
résolution n'est pas excellente si on
s'imagine à quoi ressemble vraiment un
trou noir si vous avez des en images le
film interstellar on voit des anneaux de
lumière qui entoure le trou noir qui
semble venir de dessus sur les bords
c'est des anneaux extrêmement fin et
c'est ça c'est assez a pour le moins que
ça ressemble vraiment donc à ce niveau
là oui cette photo là est flou parce
qu'elle permet pas de distinguer tous
les détails de ce qui est autour de
trous noirs et de ski de ce qui brille
donc en ce sens elle est floue après ces
lycées une image extrêmement bien défini
ses terres que hong
hong pour produire cette image il faut
avoir la définition à peu près qui
serait nécessaire pour
imaginer une balle de golf sur la lune
on va voir justement pas il ya une
animation qu'on va convaincre qu'on va
montrer voilà ça c'est comme si on
prenait la photo qu'on a fait en fait de
ceux de ce trou noir c'est comme si on
allait sur la lune alors là ce ne sera
pas une balle de golf ce sera un taux
note je vois mais l'idée c'est ça c'est
on va aller au plus près donc on est sur
quelque chose hyper hyper hyper précis
bah ouais ce quelque chose d'hyper
précis et du coup ça nécessite des
moyens
gigantesque d'autre part c'est c'est un
environnement qui donc situé au centre
de la galaxie est donc avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui sont sur
le chemin donc il ya pas mal de défis ce
serait comme on dit voilà les l'image
qui est donnée par les scientifiques
c'est à dire 'voilà ce serait comme
harry réussir à lire le journal un
journal posé à new york depuis un café à
paris mais il faut s'imaginer que ce
serait vraiment ça avec en plus une
épaisse nappe de brouillard entre les
deux entre les deux continents donc
c'est c'est l'exploit technique est
vraiment immense
mais après ça va au delà de l'exploit
technique c'est ya aussi je pense
quelque chose une dimension symbolique
qui que c'est le trou noir du central de
notre galaxie donc c'est un objet dont
donc vous avez probablement entendu
parler même si vous n'êtes pas certain
de savoir exactement de quoi on parle
vous avez probablement entendu saisir de
trous noirs supermassifs qui sont au
coeur des galaxies alors vous savez
peut-être plus très bien c'est qu'une
galaxie mais vous avais vaguement
conscience que la voie lactée c'est une
galaxie comme vous regardant le ciel
voilà et donc du coup c'est vraiment il
ya un côté un effet un peu de comment
dire de deux clochers dans le village
quoi c'est pas n'importe quel coût noir
c'est notre trou noir de galaxies et du
coup à ce titre là c'est une image qui a
quelque chose d'un peu émouvant parce
que c'est c'est un objet dont on
soupçonne l'existence depuis très
longtemps mais qu'on n'avait jamais pu
vraiment débusquer aussi finement on
était sûr qu'il était là je pourrai
revenir après sur les réseaux télécoms
était sûr qu'il était là mais on n'est
pas pour autant vu avec autant de avec
autant de certitude janvier on a fan
flâner à plusieurs des lumières il faut
pas trop en demander c'est normal
finalement il ya dominique lui aussi je
trouve normal qu'elle quelle soit fou
l'objet qu'on voit ici il est situé à
combien de la terre et ont même pu
encore être avancée on compte en années
lumière
et ces 29 mille années lumière ce qui
veut dire que si vous étiez un photon
donc l'objet le plus rapide de l'univers
il faudrait quand même 29000 en pour ces
pour parcourir la distance qui vous
sépare de la terre au trou noir donc
c'est assez loin après on raisonne
galaxie donc à ce niveau là notre
galaxie c'est donc un groupement de 100
milliards
à 200 milliards d'étoilés voit le gène
un facteur 1000 vous avez devrait
valider enfin c'est de beaucoup des
toiles
qui forment donc c'est ses bras spiraux
que vous avez je pense en tête et après
notre galaxie et dans un violent vent il
ya d'autres galaxies et l'univers
lui-même est constitué de milliard et 2
milliards de galaxies donc on est on
reste quand même dans
notre environnement très proches mais
l'espace est tellement grand et
tellement vide que voilà ça reste 28 des
lumières et
on avait pris une photo précédente
remarque était plus lointain mais on
parlera peut-être dans une autre galaxie
mais c'était beaucoup plus gros et
et voilà c'est fait sur la on peut le
voir justement on en parlera un peu plus
tard mais on va regarder un peu cette
animation qui n'a pas été fait par nous
voilà 27
millions alors j'ai perdu le chiffre
exact
salutaire à étoilé l'acm 87 étoiles qui
elle était beaucoup plus loin en fait
ouais c'est ça en gros on dit on dit
globalement qu'il était mille fois plus
loin mais mille fois plus gros et
donc voilà c'est à peu près équivalent
en termes de en termes de
définition
mais voilà ces tests et c'était beaucoup
plus loin c'était donc en compte en
centaines de millions d'années lumière
mais c'était un ogre gigantesque qui
présentait un avantage c'est qu'en fait
le tout ce qui se déroule tous les
égouts dans cette couronne autour du
trou noir se déplacent à des vitesses
proches de celle de la lumière et donc
quand l'objet petit bain ils font un
tour très rapidement en quelques
dizaines de minutes on va dire alors que
pour un trou noir beaucoup plus grands
mille fois plus grand ça plutôt mettre
quelques mois quelques années or pour
prendre cette image là on fait des poses
longues donc vous vous imaginez faire
une pause longue en train enfants qui
courent autour de sa piscine gonflable
et
une pause longue autour d'un enfant
enfin d'un bateau on va dire qu'ils qui
avance sur l'horizon ou qui fait autour
d'un lac
on en a un peu une une idée une idée
donc c'est ça qui a rendu très très
difficile l'image du trou noir central
de la galaxie ce qui a fallu tenir
compte des ses mouvements et les
corrigés par des modélisations pour
faire en sorte comme s'il restait
immobile on va dire une certaine façon
une question de blue sky alors on va en
parler maintenant peut-être qu on en
repart un peu plus tard mais quelle est
la suite après cette photo là on a pris
cette photo super maintenant qu'est-ce
que ça va nous apporter alors elle le
premier enseignement de cette photo
c'est qu'elle ressemble beaucoup à la
précédente qui avait été prise en 2019
qui avait été dévoilé en 2019 et du coup
ça c'est peut-être pas grand-chose ça
fait d'avoir chose pour vous mais
positif que c'est très important parce
que ça veut dire que entre deux trous
noirs qui ont facteur de 1000 entre leur
masse
la physique qui se déroule autour et
très sensiblement la même et c'est
exactement ce que prédit la théorie
c'est à dire que dans cet environnement
là c'est la gravité qui qui est qui est
largement dominante
et du coup tout est proportionnel un
trou noir son rayon est proportionnelle
à sa masse et tout ce qui se déroule
autour de lui va être un peu
proportionnel à sa taille donc en fait
il suffit de
zoomer on va dire entre guillemets mille
fois et on retrouve on est censé
retrouver à peu près la même la même
physique ça n'a rien d'évident
d'ordinaire dans la vie courante quand
on change d'échelle en volume les choses
augmente avec le carré où le cube de la
distance et donc on a des phénomènes à
grande et à petite échelle qui sont qui
sont très
différents qui se ressemblent pas
toujours aussi bien qu'aux qu'on peut
l'imaginer donc c'est un des grands
enseignements et ensuite il ce qu'on va
faire caler la suite comme je le disais
c'est des environnements qui sont
dynamiques c'est pas c'est pas quelque
chose qui est figé on a l'habitude dans
l'espace que les choses se déroule
relativement lentement parce que
justement c'est très grand mais là on
est sur des distances finalement très
petit avec des choses qui bougent très
vite avec la lumière et donc l'espoir
c'est d'arriver dans le futur avec le
temps à faire à faire des images
dynamiques voilà deux des portes
réanimer des petites vidéos pour essayer
de voir un peu l'évolution de cette
chose là que l'autre possibilité c'est
de faire ce qui a été fait pour m 87 à
une très belle image vous invite à aller
la voir il ya une image en lumière
polarisée alors
bon ça c'est un peu compliqué on voit
pas nous la lumière de manière paul
arrivé mais les les oiseaux par exemple
peuvent voir la lumière polarisée et ça
veut dire qu'on voit que des différences
de la lumière en fonction de l'angle du
champ électromagnétique c'est un peu
compliqué mais l'idée générale c'est que
ça va nous donner des informations sur
l'environnement magnétique du trou noir
et l'environnement magnétique du trou
noir c'est extrêmement important parce
que c'est ce champ magnétique là qui va
dont va dépendre plein plein de
phénomènes notamment les jets de
particules etc bon il ya plein plein de
physique derrière qui est très
intéressante et la troisième chose c'est
d'arriver à affiner cette image là et
donc pour affiner cette image là il ya
plusieurs solutions il ya utiliser les
télescopes plus éloignés les uns des
autres donc là il ya il ya deux
télescopes très puissant qui sont entrés
en service et qui vont permettre
d'agrandir un pelé on fera sans la tuer
en gros on essaie d'améliorer l'image
pour la voir justement de manière moins
floue manière le plus précise
et voilà et un bond à terme l'idéal
serait d'avoir des scop sur la lune
typiquement et de faire marcher ce que
l'on obtiendrait du coup on arrive à
faire en faisant fonctionner des
télescopes sur la lune et sur terre on
arriverait à
décupler la définition et à se
rapprocher vraiment de cette image type
interstellaire effectivement alors là
sango remise fielder qui nous dit cette
image de trous noirs date donc de 27
mille ans alors oui oui a évidemment
comme tout ce qui est dit comme tout ce
qui se passe dans le dans l'espace alors
l'avons 29 mai dans l échelle de la vie
d'un trou noir c'est pas grand chose
mais à l'échelle d'une vie d'une étoile
même à l'échelle de vie à l'échelle de
la terre voire même à l'échelle de
l'évolution c'est pas grand chose
elle est celle d'une vie humaine
évidemment ça semble très long mais oui
les foules et les photons là qu'ils ont
été capturés ont mis 27 mille ans à nous
parvenir et
est donc c'est ce décalage jamais bon
quand on regarde plus loin quand on
regarde les premières délai fallait plus
ancienne galaxie où les premières
galaxies ça dépend comment on regarde
les choses au regard des choses qui qui
sont telles qu'elles étaient il ya 13 5
milliards d'années donc c'est encore
c'est encore d'autres d'autres échelles
mais oui on rien de ce qu'on voit sur le
ciel finalement né comme ils étaient
entraînés en fait la notion même de
l'instantanéité dans l'univers a pas
vraiment de sens ne serait ce que parce
que le temps ne s'écoule pas de la même
manière partout donc
le l'écoulement du temps autour d'un
trou noir est pas du tout le même que
l'écoulement du temps sur terre donc ça
veut dire quoi au même moment pour le
trou noir et pour nous c'est des notions
qui n'ont plus vraiment de plus grand de
sens et l'instantanéité est là elle a un
sens parce qu'on est dans un
environnement sur terre
voilà particulier mais mais mais ça
voilà ça s'apparente au sens physique
les les les photos qui ont obligé les
plus rapides l'univers se déplace très
très doucement le photo qui vient du
soleil mais neuf minutes ça nous
parvenir donc si vous regardez ça soit
une image à l'échelle vous aurez
vraiment l'impression que le photon il
se traîne quoi pareil il faut il faut
une seconde fin des retour vers la lune
fin voilà donc la première étoile ces
quatre 4 années lumière donc ces quatre
ans et c'est là tout la plus proche de
nous toutes les autres que vous ayez
dans le ciel globalement elles sont à
venir quelques centaines quelques
milliers d'années lumière pas plus
et après il ya quelques galaxies que
vous arrivez à voir quelques millions
d'années loué quelques centaines de
milliers d'années lumière que nous
quelques millions d'années lumière et
puis c'est après tout quoi donc on a
blue sky dans les commentaires qui nous
pose une question qui est assez
intéressante pour la peau pour la
technique qui a été utilisée de deux
mais ils nous demandent avec l appareil
photo a été prise cette fausse cette
photo finalement alors c'est pas
vraiment un appareil photo mais c'est
cette épreuve des antennes radio qu'on
peut voir là donc c'est des antennes
cdd grande coupole qui vont récupérer le
rayonnement radio qui vient du ciel qui
vont le faire converger à l'intérieur de
leur cabine et qui vont enregistrer
signal on prend le signal de plein
d'antennes comme ça la surface de la
terre et ensuite on va les faire on va
les mettre ensemble on dirait fin on va
les faire interférer
et donc qu'on valait les combinés
ensemble pour simuler un
télescope plus grands en fait la
résolution d'un télescope elles
dépendent de sa de la taille de sa de sa
coupole plus la coupole est grande plus
on va arriver à avoir des détails fins
on peut le comprendre de manière
relativement intuitive
et donc là l'idée c'est de prendre pied
scop à différents endroits et de faire
intervenir leur lumière et ça te donne
ça fait comme si on avait un télescope
qui faisait la taille qui sépare les
télescopes alors la surface en revanche
la sensibilité donc la surface des
coupoles c'est la somme je découpe holtz
et on peut pas gagner là dessus mais par
contre on peut aligner en résolution et
voir des objets beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus fin et donc on a les asiatiques ont
fait ça avec eux je sais plus et sept ou
huit
sites dans les délais ce cop dont chaque
site et parfois constitué de plusieurs
antennes fille comme en allemagne à une
cinquantaine qui interfèrent déjà entre
elles d'après on met ces données-là en
en lien avec les autres et c'est ce
travail là qui est très compliqué de de
mise de mise en commun des données parce
qu'il faut connaître la position
relative par exemple des télescopes
demeure extrêmement précises avec une
pression lors de la longueur d'onde
c'est à dire en l'occurrence du l'ordre
du millimètre donc faut savoir voilà si
vous êtes antenne qui est perché dans
une montagne au nord du chili celle
qu'on peut voir là de l'iram en espagne
il faut connaître la pression relative
au millimètre près et il s'annonce n'est
pas le faire
d'ailleurs c'est même l'inversé ça c'est
que si on arrive aujourd'hui à calculer
la dérive des continents
c'est grâce à cette technique là alors
c'est pas fake du minime et avec ces
mêmes radiotélescope mais ça fait que
des radiotélescopes qui arrange qui
pointe une étoile eux connu et après on
fait interférer leurs signaux et
qu'enfin tafer leurs signaux on arrive
en déduire la distance exacte qui sépare
les deux télescopes
du coup on arrive comme ça à mesurer la
dérive des continents avec des
précisions de l'ordre de quelques
millimètres ou quelques centimètres on a
justement une question sur plutôt la
dangerosité d'un trou noir coqueline
demande et alors il nous disait tout à
l'heure est-ce que c'était dangereux et
est-ce qu'on peut se faire aspirer par
un trou noir alors oui et non
on a souvent l'image puis moi le premier
quand j'en ai parlé des trous noirs
d'une espèce de siphon cosmique qui
attire tout ce qui est autour de lui
était tout va plonger c'est pas
exactement comme ça parce qu'en fait le
les règles de la de la mécanique sont
assez sont assez variés des envies de
stable autour d'un trou noir exactement
si le tweet yves un civil et un trou
noir de la tas de la masse de notre
soleil au centre du système solaire on
pourrait nourrir est normalement
normalement autour sans tomber sur lui
les choses devient plus compliqué quand
on se rapproche vraiment du trou noir et
notamment quand quand vraiment on va
arriver au niveau de l'horizon donc
vraiment proche du trou noir c'est là
que la grosse sphère noire qu'on voit là
sur l'image qu'a fait la singularité en
fait ça c'est une zone autour du trou
noir de laquelle on va disparaître et on
pourra jamais revenir en arrière
et puis alors là il ya des problèmes il
ya des effets de marée qui font que
typiquement vous pourriez traversée
l'horizon un trou noir
si vous étiez un point on peut traverser
horizon trouvera sans problème on irait
voir ce qui est autorisé
après le fait est qu'il ya en fait des
différences de gravité extrêmement forte
et entre le vos pieds votre tête centre
même des frères elric fait que ça vous
déchire en fait en deux ce serait une
bonne expérience
à faire donc voilà c'est pas forcément
le talent choses à faire après c'est
suffisamment loin pour qu'on n'est pas
en temps le procureur ne se pose pas
pour l'instant non et puis se posera
jamais le par exemple on a l'image de la
voie lactée des branagh voie lactée qui
tourne autour du trou noir central c'est
pas du tout le cas la dynamique de la
voie lactée les bras tourne et c'est n'a
rien à voir avec le trou noir le trou
noir il a une influence sur son
environnement proche et donc des étoiles
qui tourne très vite autour d'eux lui et
ses fils à l'affluence mais qui est très
localisée vraiment j'avais pris cette
image si on prend le si on prend la
taille de la voie lactée et qu on la
rapporte à paris intra muros vous vous
imprimez la voie lactée sur un grand
gigantesque étoile qui fait la taille de
paris intra muros et vous venez au
milieu de s'être de cette toile vous
prenez une aiguille très fine vous
percer un trou
qui va être à peine visible à l'oeil nu
et ça c'est la taille du trou noir
central sa sphère d'influencé même pas
un millimètre
sur 7 sur cette voie lactée voie lactée
qui fait la taille de paris intra muros
donc vous vous ça donne un peu une idée
de
des distances qui sont en jeu qui n'ont
rien à voir avec ce qu'on peut
s'imaginer donc non le un trou noir ne
représentant lui-même aucun danger
particulier sauf de 560 approché très
près mais on n'est pas encore là a
priori par rapport par rapport à la
terre
quelle est la différence de taille entre
un trou noir et la terre
alors j'ai pas exactement cette image là
en tête mais
on va dire que un trou noir qui ferait
la masse du soleil serait je crois bien
plus petite que la terre
mais là il faut voir c'est un donc un
trou noir qui fait 4 millions 2,4
millions de fois la masse de notre
soleil et il tient dans un espace
qui est compris entre la surface du
soleil et mercure qui est la planète la
plus proche du soleil donc c'est
vraiment
c'est pas énorme c'est assez vraiment un
petit objet un trou noir même un trou
noir supermassif ça parce que on parle
de trou noir supermassif donc on
s'attend à ce qu'ils soient très lourd
des normes et part on sait que parce
qu'ils sont très lourds et b pas
forcément très long ils sont très bons
mais pour cette raison qu'ils sont pas
très grands essais de la matière très
dense en fait est alors très dense tout
est relatif presque pour un point sur
l'effectif ce qu'on appelle les quelque
chose de très denses et pas forcément
très dense pour détruire un très très
très massif ils peuvent voir la densité
de l'eau par exemple ce qui est un peu
contre intuitif mais c'est une énorme
masse
rassembler un endroit un petit endroit
voilà la danse étaient des étoiles par
exemple c'est pas forcément aussi dense
que ce qu'on peut s'imaginer donc à
l'échelle d'un l'échelle de l'univers
voilà c'est ça vous donne quelques idées
et vous disais au début de ce live on
savait que ce trou noir étaient là avant
ouais on le sait depuis
ce faire alors enfin tout ça s'est fait
tout s'est fait par étape mais on a
commencé par détecter une source d'une
radio dans la constellation du
sagittaire très intense je sais à peu
près 50 ans et puis après on s'est rendu
compte qu'au sein de cette émission
radio il y avait encore un point bien
plus brillant en radio
venant de ces endroits et donc on a
baptisé donc sagittarius à la première
émission radio puis la celle qui est
encore plus petit cgt à étoiles et on
s'est demandé ce que ça pouvait être est
assez rapidement on a joué dans cette
zone à risque et observer les étoiles et
le mouvement des étoiles extrêmement
rapide autour de cette radio est très
intense a permis de calculer la masse
qui devait se trouver au centre et donc
on est arrivé après un chiffre de 4
millions de masses solaires dans un
volume
tellement petit que en fait ça pouvait
pas être autre chose qu'un trou noir
d'après la théorie de la relativité d'un
gênant pouvait pas imaginer avoir autant
de
autant de matière dans un volume aussi
petit sans qu'ils se fondre sur lui même
jusqu'à créer ce qu'on avait une
singularité donc un trou noir justement
ce ce trou noir
c'est en tout cas ce cliché de trou noir
il a été diffusé la semaine dernière
mais quand est ce qu'il a été réalisé
est ce que est ce qu'on aille à
reconnaître qu'on a une datation du
moment où on a pris ce cliché web au
printemps 2017
pendant une semaine de prise de mesures
en gros en gros c'est assez compliqué
parce qu'il faut donc que tout c'est
vrai tous ces observateurs du monde
entier observe en même temps donc il a
fait les coordonnées il faut faire en
sorte que il mesure très précisément
le
championnat je temporel qu'ils ont tous
des horloges atomiques de très haute
résolution qui les équipes qu'il a fallu
en équipe et certains observateurs qui
n'en avaient pas il faut s'assurer que
voilà qui en gros qui parlent le même
langage
qu'on va pouvoir combiner des signaux
donc c'est pas du tout quelque chose de
trivial
et donc il faut les faire fonctionner
tous en même temps vers la même cible
pendant au même moment et donc tu as une
couleur une collaboration qui s'est
montée qui s'appelle les 22 reisenthel
scop dont l'objectif était d' images et
le trou noir central de notre voie
lactée qui s'est mis en place petit à
petit à partir de la fin des années 2000
une début des années 2010 et ils ont
réussi à effectuer leur première
campagne d'une semaine de prise de
mesures sur sept ou huit sites en même
temps ensuite les verts ont été
enregistrés dans des
disques durs le il ya des volumes de
données
énormes
c'était plus pratique que le plus rapide
c'est de rester droit y est là par la
pause ouest sa part
envoyé de telle ou telle quantité de
données par internet ça prendrait trop
de temps fait le plus rapide c'est
encore d'envoyer un disque d'or à la
poste c'est c'est
une des particularités et du coup il en
fait en 2007 pour la première fois ça a
très bien fonctionné la chance du
débutant et pas trop la météo il faut
aussi qu'il fasse beau prêts sur tous
les sites en même temps
pas de problème météo pas de problème
technique tout a bien marché et donc
quand ils ont publié une première photo
de
2087 étoiles en 2019 parce qu'il était
plus facile à images et il a fallu faire
beaucoup de traitements données
supplémentaires pour arriver en deux
années supplémentaires à faire l'image
de sagittarius à l'étoile
les astronomes disent en gros que
l'image était prête depuis après un an
après il a fallu se mettre d'accord et
ce qu'on est sûr que le traitement de
l'image qu'on a fait des données
correctes comme on va communiquer sur
ces voies c'est moins de la science
c'est à dire que c'est du terral plus
est et est 1087 étoiles
les jets et doit d'ailleurs les les deux
ils ont été pris les blés faute on était
prêts en même temps et dans la même
campagne de mesure la comaga mesure a
été divisé en deux il pointe elle à une
partie du temps sur 1,87 étoiles et une
partie du temps sur sagittarius à
étoiles et là ça a pris cinq ans avant
alors que pour le cadre à cette étoile
ça a pris deux ans c'est ça en gros il a
fallu deux trois années de plus de
traitement de données pour pour se
convaincre que que voilà que ce qu'on a
et que publie aujourd'hui était bien
l'image de sagittarius à étoilé de la
couronne de gaz et de poussières qui
l'entourent et qui aimait ce rayonnement
radio entre autres et comment pour
l'expliquer ce ce de trois ans de plus
c'est ça qui est qui compliquait à
il ya différents traitements de données
en fait il faut voir que le sur la ligne
de visée et elle est moins propre pour
le voie lactée parce qu'il ya regarde
vers le centre de notre galaxie
il ya beaucoup de choses sur le chemin
notamment du gaz la poussière quand on
regarde vers l'extérieur de notre
galaxie du coup on va dire que la ligne
de visée un peu plus pur un peu plus
dégagé donc il faudra corriger cet effet
là restés fidèles et danses a dispersé
par exemple les ondes radio en fréquence
je vous passe les détails mais en gros
ça altère le signal il faut corriger
tous ses effets là
après il ya le fait que le trou noir
bouger et donc il a fallu
modéliser
la manière anti pouget l'effet que ça
aurait sans le rayonnement l'angle sous
lequel on ne voyait pour arriver à
remonter à son image et ça c'est plein
de traitement de données mais qui
n'existe pas il ya pas de logiciel eux
qu'il faut le vouloir créer vous
vérifiez qui marche ensuite faut la
faire plein de tests différents pour
être sûr que ça qu'on se trompe pas
qu'on n'est pas en train de
et donc c'est ça qui prend
qui prend beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
temps et voilà donc qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour la suite d'un en 2018 2019
les campagnes n'ont pas été aussi
concluante unique a pu être mené parce
qu'il avait trop de l'observatoire qui
était déconnecté en 2018 des problèmes
météo ou inversement je sais plus et en
le coc vide juste avant que la campagne
ait lieu donc pareil ça peut vivre et
donc ils ont pu ils ont réussi à refaire
une campagne en 2021 qui était réussie
et là cette année en 2022 et donc le
temps de traitement des données
peut-être que l'année prochaine en deux
ans on aura des images
un peu plus sensible un peu plus un peu
plus un peu meilleurs mais on va pas
durablement pas de saut qualitatif
extrêmement important ça va plus être
des des voix là deux choses un peu de
spécialistes entre guillemets alors je
salue les les différences internautes
qui nous veut qu'ils nous ont rejoints
comme 945 stocky jours et on avait eu
par exemple une question de goku gainey
de toute façon il faut un vaisseau
extrêmement rapide pour ce trajet alors
imaginons qu'on a un vaisseau aussi
rapide pour y aller le problème c'est
qu'il faut que le corps humain le
supporter se tramait ben alors après il
faudrait imaginer un vaisseau
accélération très lente mais continue
pour supporter évidemment on peut pas
passer 2 020 à la vitesse de la lumière
automatiquement sinon on est broyé
littéralement broyé
bac une expiration continue qui leur est
d'atteindre la vitesse de la lumière ou
même même une fraction la vitesse de la
lumière ce qui n'est pas faisable
aujourd'hui mettons 10 % de la vitesse
de la lumière il faudrait quand même de
190 milan pour y avait donc
les seules solutions pas les seuls à des
solutions et seule chose qu'on puisse
imaginer à l'heure actuelle pour
vraiment
visible cosmo ce serait de découvrir une
nouvelle physique ou alors découvrir des
objets
qui comme les fameux trou de ver on vous
avez probablement entendu parler
c'est un peu le scénario de interstellar
voilà serait d'avoir
l'espace temps qui a un endroit créer un
pont entre deux zones très très très
très éloignées ça ça paraît être un peu
un peu fou mais c'est délicat parce
qu'on n'a jamais trouvé on n'est pas
certain que ça existe mais mais bon
pourquoi pas quoi mais en l'état actuel
oui c'est un peu les seules manières
qu'ont peu
qui reste on va dire pour rêver de
pouvoir voyager un jour dans le cosmos
déjà exprimé notre système solaire c'est
effroyablement compliquée l'an
il faut déjà qu'on arrivait sur mars un
jour ou l'autre sa pensée en mars autour
et soit la lune puis après voilà allez
voir les jambes gazeuse ceinture
d'astéroïdes tout ça
c'est pas simple on n'est pas une on
n'est pas une espèce
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas la durée de
vie assez longue est ce que c'est parce
que c'est foncièrement impossible ce
qu'on est cantonné à notre voie la
plus physique svelte à ce qu'il dit est
ce que c'est vrai qu'en plongeant dans
un trou noir on voit l'univers
s'accélérer autour de nous
alors est ce qu'on va devenir
s'accélérer en plongée dans un trou noir
je sais pas exactement ce que quelle
serait la vision
qu'on a mais oui tout va nous sembler le
temps va incroyablement ralentir pour
nous
de l'extérieur on aura l'air immobile
et donc oui l'univers nova nous semble
accélérer après je ce que je maîtrise
âge c'est comment est-ce qu'on va
percevoir du coup les photons ce que les
photons eux mêmes quand il a arrêté ils
vont arriver vers nous ils vont ralentir
et donc je sais pas comment dire le
l'oeil est pas quelque chose qui s'est
pas une interaction à distance l'oeil il
reçoit des photons et qu'ils arrivent
jusqu'à l'oeil donc je me suis sûr que
des physiciens ont fait ça vous ne vous
trouvez ça pour long sur un traître mais
qui l'est les photos eux mêmes vont
ralentir donc
je sais pas c'est le maître qui sont je
sais pas exactement à quoi ressemblerait
l'univers point de vue de l'extérieur
vraiment on a l'impression de
elle seule raison d'être noir de dial
est de plus en plus doucement si on
pouvait aller parce que notre chat se
porte volontaire pour envoyer un robot
dans le trou noir pour voir un peu ce
qui pourrait se passer mais on ne va pas
envie de vous
ce
serait même un trou noir stellaire dans
l'acte est beaucoup plus proche est
aujourd'hui veuve j'étais un objet qui
est sorti du système solaire cela
soulagera on vient les années 80 et elle
vient à peine de franchir ce qu'on
appelle les lieux au pot c'est à dire
les zones d'influencé valeur la bulle de
vent solaire dans laquelle on est on est
on est on est très très loin encore mais
très très très très loin je vais insiste
à la vitesse à laquelle va j'ai fait le
calcul jeux les plus en tête mais ce
qu'on en dizaines de milliers d'années
avant qu'elle arrive à l'étoile la plus
proche les quatre années lumière donc
c'est à l'étranger les ordres de
grandeur qui sont complètement
différents ouais c'est dur de prendre la
mesure du vide de l'espace tout comme à
cette page de la voie lactée peint des
toiles on dire mais on les voit sur un
côté en fait non elle s'était
c'est évident on a bousculé qui lui
demandait ce qu'il appelle un trou noir
plus proche est ce qu'on aurait pu avoir
un autre noir plupart des trous noirs
pour poche évidemment il y en a
mais le
le problème c'est que on sait pas de
jaloux ils sont
par définition on les voit pas
il ya forcément des trous noirs notre
galaxie des traumas stellaire de on va
dire quelques masses solaires
quelquefois la masse notre seul essai
c'est ça se produit quand une étoile
très massive en fin de vie ses fonctions
elle même
c'est une masse suffisante elle va elle
va donner un trou noir le problème c'est
que par défi quand on sait pas où ils
sont
et ce qu'on arrive à observer ces
fusions de trous noirs mais des
événements rares donc on essaie observe
assez lointain dont qui se produisent
pas dans notre dans notre voie lactée de
nos coûts seraient tout simplement pas
où regarder alors on peut poser
plication quand même aussi parce que
j'avais dans le théâtre c'est ce qu'on
voit sur cette photo finalement c'est
trois zones brillante et un point au
milieu qu'est ce qu'est ce que c'est
exactement est ce qu'on s'est un peu
qu'est ce que c'est exactement alors on
on pense avoir apprécié cc on pense
qu'on regarde le trou noir à peu près
par le dessus et donc que ce conte ce
qu'on voit c'est le son disque
d'accrétion donc c'était le la gaz le
gaz et la poussière qui tourne autour de
lui à des vitesses extrêmement rapide
proche de celle de la lumière donc le
gaz
se débarrasse on va dire ces électrons
et ionisent et du coup ils électro qui
vont tourner aussi les électrons quand
il tourne les maîtres des rayonnement
synchrotron
ça a aimé dans le domaine
des rayons x a aimé dans la radio ça
aimé du rayonnement visible s'est
améliorée long terme xss et un feu
d'artifice à aimer d'entrer dans toutes
les couleurs possibles on regarde dans
la dent dans le domaine radio parce que
c'est les poussières et les gars sont à
peu près transparent dans ce domaine de
longueur d'onde ça ça perturbe le signal
mais il arrive à passer il ya plein
plein de rien de moi qui juste sont
bloqués donc c'est on ne verrait pas du
tout donc c'est un peu ça quand on peut
observer après il ya des effets
relativistes c'est à dire que le
les
dans un environnement un trou noir la
gravité est tellement forte que les
photons sont détournés donc ne vont pas
tout droit mais mais mais mais tourne
autour du trou noir et certains viennent
par dessus et donc on observe un image
qui a été fait qu'on a vraiment dedans
et interstella encore une fois que les
tricks et très bien sa différence que
interstellar ils ont fait un objet
symétrique henry trash d'un effet à
c'est un peu différent c'est que quand
les photons viennent vers nous ils nous
apparaissent plus lumineux que quand il
s'écarte de nous par effet doppler c'est
un peu compliqué expliqué on a
l'impression qu'on comprend pourquoi
mais on n'est pas sûr non sylvie aux
besoins communs on se dira obtient ce
qu'il faut te vient vers moi oui il est
plus lumineux que s'il s'en écarte
donc maintenant que temps que oui mais
toi que oui voilà il ya un effet
physique derrière qui cliquent ça qui
amplifie le qui amplifie le signal perçu
et donc c'est ce qu'on pense être ces
blocs de lumière c'est c'est quand la
lumière vient vers nous il y en a il ya
un des des blogs ceux de gauche qui est
un peu moins clair donc là on pense
qu'en gros il ya de la lumière qui vient
vers nous par le côté de l'émir qui
vient vers nous parle dessus et à gauche
c'est moins clair c'est ça pour être
alerté fac de mesure où ça pourrait être
quelque chose qui est lié à quelque
chose qui est pas dans le plan mais qui
serait un pas un plein jets de matière
tu le fait que les doigts
voilà si on met donc en garde le trou
noir comme ça il y avait 1 g de matière
un peu sur le côté il viendrait vers
nous donc il y aurait de la lumière qui
aiment par dessus la lumière qui vient
par la du disque et il y aurait en plus
de la lumière qui vient de sujets par
exemple ça pourrait tout c'est un
artefact
deux mesures c'est peut-être plus
d'image plus détaillée peut-être qu'ils
pourraient disparaître très bien merci
beaucoup triste en tout cas d'avoir
aujourd'hui pour parler de ce trou noir
de cette photo qui comme on l'a dit est
probablement la photo de l'année en
sciences ouais je pense qu'on peut le
dire voilà on peut le dire merci à vous
en tout cas d'avoir été là merci à
raphaël à drake était en régie avec nous
et je vous donne rendez vous bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives sur figaro live